how to reconcile gravity with quantum
mechanics I think that's the one that
keeps most people
from most people for sure
because again you didn't get to sleep
till three in the morning constantly
[Music]
this is StarTalk and Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today we're doing a cosmic queries
Edition always a fan favorite and I've
got a co-host with me nagine facade
Nadine welcome back to Star Talk how
hello Neil oh my God I love being back
this feels so right it feels so good
[Laughter]
the universe always feels right let me
just put it that way true to say
so uh we have a guest a friend and a
colleague who uh in Fall 2022 published
a book called the biggest ideas in the
universe
space time and motion now you know my
people publish books like that you know
only my people can put titles on books
we got this nigging so let me welcome
back Sean Carroll Sean welcome back to
start talk thanks very much Neil it's
good to have a personal astrophysicist
around I have some problems that I want
to send you when you were done here no
if if you have a problem with them I
I don't know what I can do for you on
this so uh we we have notes Here on you
we call you a physicist but also a
philosopher and recently
um you hail from John Johns Hopkins
University and the Santa Fe Institute
and so is the Philosopher's side of you
that which is aligned with the Santa Fe
Institute because there's some deep
thinkers about some weird stuff over
Santa Fe there are but they're not
aligned actually the Santa Fe Institute
is a wonderful place it's the research
institute devoted to studying complexity
complex systems from physics to biology
to economics and the internet uh but
they're actually a little bit just to be
clear Sean just just settle for rights
once and for all the difference between
complex and complicated that's a very
good question and nobody knows the
answer so I'm not going to settle for it
one Central one of the one of the
refrains that Santa Fe is just don't ask
us what complexity is like we'll tell
you things about it but the goal is not
to find the once and for all definition
of it
I think like if there's like an easy
comedian's uh rule about that which is
just like if there's more than three
things that you have to understand it's
complex in the joke I got it yeah okay
all right and then she needed like
higher IQ audience to deliver it
yeah I only perform for Mensa right all
right
where I am
um Sean you're also host of the podcast
mindscape I love that title and just
just to settle it once and for all you
are the physicist Sean Carroll not the
biologist Sean Carroll correct I am
although if people are interested there
is an episode of mindscape where I
interview the biologist John Carroll my
evil twin with the beard that would be
way too confusing for me it was the
transcription people had troubles but
that's okay
officially complex right there yeah
so uh so this book what what was you've
written
several books right and so what
compelled you to land here in uh space
time in motion we had a little thing
called the pandemic no I've heard of
that there yeah pandemic projects right
and so my project was I made a series of
videos where they were explaining
physics to people because that's
something that I know about that might
be used full but of course it's also
been done before so the gimmick I had
was that I actually showed you the
equations I did not hide the equations
from people and I taught you the math it
was it wasn't that you were supposed to
be an expert already so I taught people
calculus derivatives integrals complex
numbers and then we learned all the
equations of physics and so now do you
hear what he said just to be clear he
said he taught you the math it didn't
mean you learned instituted two
different actions
see he's being precise in his
communication I taught the math right no
matter what came out on the other side
that's the idea and again you would love
this book if you don't already know the
math this is your chance is it you know
are we talking is it just like a basic
addition maybe some long-form division
or it's way more than that but you get
taught it and then you learn it and it's
great you're a different person
afterward
the rumor has it and actually it wasn't
just rumor I heard it from the person
who said it that the original editor
for Stephen Hawking's A Brief History of
Time this was at Cambridge press
warned him that for every equation he
put in that book The Available audience
to him would be cut in half
all right so two equations is one four
three equations it's one-eighth and he
nonetheless put in equations in fact
they didn't even sign the book it went
to another publisher and it became the
biggest selling science book of all time
so Sean you maybe you're in really
excellent tradition here I have a
hundred equations so if they all cut my
audience in half the audience would be
very very tiny you can do the math two
to the 100th power oh my gosh I'm gonna
do that right now
Neil Reddit
[Laughter]
space time in motion that's that these
are fundamental concepts in physics I
don't know how much we would know of the
universe if we didn't know those three
very well so do you have any special
insights you want to share before we go
to q a well the basic idea is that we
took the series of videos I did which
cover a lot of material and we chopped
them up into three books so this is the
first book of a Trilogy which as I like
to say is a format that works well for
the Lord of the Rings and other famous
franchises
so this is the fellowship of physics and
it's basically classical physics right
it's the physics before quantum
mechanics came along but that still
takes us very far by the end of the book
you've learned Einstein's equation of
general relativity and you look at the
short Shield metric for black holes and
you know why there are black holes it's
a it's a different level of
understanding than you would get if you
just looked at words and metaphors and
pictures
okay excellent so it's it's a unique uh
pedagogical addition to what's otherwise
on the Shelf that's the idea that that's
always important that's right okay so I
did 2 to the hundredth power and I got
uh
and I got a one with 30 zeros why did
you do that well I would love it
it's a very big number
yeah so it's that fraction of the total
humans who have ever been born it's less
than one person yeah
what was in there again a fractional
Neil again
that should be like the tagline for
yourself
so so Nadine what uh you have your stash
of questions there I do and
um this first one comes from Dylan in
Flagstaff Dylan asks is someone who's
studying physics and astrophysics what
would it mean to discover what comprises
dark matter and dark energy what could
we then do and how would that drive
future discoveries of our unknown
Universe I love that Sean where do you
sits on that yeah I mean dark matter and
dark energy uh we have very very good
reasons to believe that they exist we
know how much of them there are we even
know more or less where they are we
don't know exactly what they are we know
some features of them there's a very
leading candidate for dark energy which
is just the energy of empty space itself
what Einstein called the cosmological
constant the dark matter much less of a
clear idea what it could be many many
good ideas what it might be but we don't
know which one and when we do discover
which one which I'm very optimistic that
we're going to do we'll be able to do
essentially nothing with it
to answer the question it's not going to
lead to a better warp drive or electric
vehicles or anything like that because
you know of well no I do I do kind of
know that okay because it's dark which
means it doesn't interact with
electricity or magnetism so be that's
why it's so hard to find it we can't
touch it we have to use like the weak
interactions of particle physics or
something else super duper clever even
just to locate one particle of dark
matter and to do that you need a giant
experiment it doesn't even touch itself
right so we can't go around looking for
Dark Matter planets or Stars no but yes
the simplest idea is it doesn't it
doesn't interact with itself at all
maybe it interacts a little bit and
that's a very active area of research
mm-hmm
I did write a paper once on could there
be dark photons could there be dark
light
in other words could there be a kind of
light that interacts with dark matter
particles but not with visible matter
particles and interestingly the answer
is yes there could be and then you could
get like dark magnetic fields maybe even
dark atoms who knows
I feel like dark therapy needs a dark
matter needs a little therapy
I saw some comic wizard somewhere and it
says they discovered a new kind of
particle
um you know and they had a dark matter
and this other camera and this is called
doesn't matter that's a new kind of
particle it doesn't matter at all to
what it is but plus Sean you have to
admit you sounded like you're just
making stuff up when you said uh we had
to explain Dark Energy so the vacuum of
space has energy there it is that's your
attack that sounded very cloogy I just
want to put it out there well I will
recommend that people who think it's uh
clergy and making things up buy a book
that I recently wrote that explains how
general relativity Works among other
things uh and but it really is I mean
that's a joke but it's also kind of true
I mean this is one of the things about
trying to explain physics as you know
using metaphors and analogies and
stories that it makes some things become
clear and other things main murky until
you look at the equations and so like if
you know the equations of general
relativity the idea that empty space has
energy is just like the most obvious
simple thing in the world it's a
surprise we haven't found it long ago
cool cool because it's part of the
equation part of the equations yeah
Einstein invented it almost you know the
year after general relativity itself so
it was not that hard I love how your the
implication there is like even an idiot
like Einstein
a year after I mean what a dumb dumb
um Dave from Milwaukee asks what
unanswered questions keep you up at
night
there's an obvious one that keeps
everyone up at night I think which is
how to reconcile gravity with quantum
mechanics I think that's the one that
keeps most people
from pretty much people for sure
because again you didn't get to sleep
till three in the morning oh my God
like that that and like what who's gonna
be the breakout star of Real Housewives
of Atlanta those are the two main things
that just I'd keep it the similar
questions I heard them talking about it
on Real Housewives so I think that
they're interested
because they know that these are the two
great triumphant discoveries of 20th
century physics right quantum mechanics
discovering how atoms and particles
behave general relativity Einstein's
theory of gravity which tells us about
black holes in the Big Bang but they're
incompatible with each other at a deep
level and so people have been trying for
decades now some pretty smart cookies to
make a single theory that unifies them
together and we don't think we're quite
there yet
so let me let me be a little bit of a
devil's advocate here just because
they're not compatible at certain ways
you might want to intersect them uh why
do you require why do you require that
the Universe has an understanding that
we have yet to achieve that makes them
compatible
why can't we just have a universe we
have two completely perfect theories of
the universe and they're just not
compatible like so you have a
philosophical uh uh prior here where you
want things to be elegant and beautiful
and maybe they're just not sure things
might not be elegant and beautiful but
things do make sense things happen one
way or the other quantum mechanics says
that something like a spinning particle
can be in a superposition of two
different states spinning clockwise and
spinning counterclockwise and that's all
fine and we understand what's going on
Schrodinger's cat if you've known that
it's a superposition of a cat being
alive and a cat being dead so take the
Earth and imagine just in your thought
experiment uh capabilities imagine a
superposition of the Earth being here
and the Earth being somewhere else
that needs to have a gravitational field
what is it is it pointing in One
Direction or the other or in between
there has to be an answer to that
question we don't know it yet
okay by the way there's a movie called
Another Earth where oh yeah there's an
earth and then another Earth
is that what the title means
I just really wanted to break that down
for you because I know that's really
complicated that's Brit Marley's story
right yeah exactly it's a Sci-Fi uh
author and producer an act an actress I
was actually on the jury for a prize at
the Sundance Film Festival where we gave
a prize to another Earth uh the Sloan
movie prize which is given to a movie
that has something to do with science
and so we gave him the prize it was a
good movie we didn't we kind of worried
whether it had anything to do with
science or not but then we we asked them
afterward what was your inspiration for
this another Earth idea and they said we
heard a radio interview with Brian
Greene talking about the Multiverse so
we got the idea from that so it actually
paid off it had enough science in it I
mean a very science fictiony but it was
there was enough science given uh
special attention that uh I thought I
gave a two thumbs up for sure yeah yeah
so all right Nadine keep them coming I
also love that like this is the panel of
three nerds that saw that movie Another
Earth which was not a huge mainstream
Blockbuster point that out we're talking
about the festival film here okay
so Kevin the sommelier asks does the
conservation of energy go out the window
in relation to the expanding Universe
where is the extra energy coming from oh
you know actually we gotta take a quick
break when we come back we're going to
find out what Sean Carroll is doing with
the energy of the expanding universe
when start talk returns
we're back start talk Cosmic queries
Edition with my friend and colleague
Sean Carroll who's got a new book out
which has the audacious title the kind
of titles that only my people can dare
the biggest ideas in the universe space
time and motion congratulations on this
your next book with published with
Dutton Dutton press uh so we got Nadine
negeen we left off with a question
dangling
we want to find out what Sean Carroll
does with all this energy where does he
get it from that's forcing an
accelerating universe to expand and
who's the one who asked that question
that's right Kevin the sommelier asked
about you have the samal yeah he's going
to tell she's a Somalia and not also
tell us what he's drinking you know next
time
entry is here he's got to tell us what
his latest cool wine is so that we can
all go out and buy it okay exactly he's
asking if the conservation of energy
goes out the window in relation to the
expanding universe and where does the
extra energy come from yeah Sean and
let's take that with the with the dark
energy side of this well you know one of
my minor claims to fame is that if you
Google energy is not conserved the first
hit is a blog post I wrote explaining
why energy is not conserved in an
expanding universe but it's not that you
know all hell has broken loose what's
happening is that as space time itself
is changing it can sort of sap energy
out of matter and particles or give
energy back to the matter and particles
so if you forget about dark energy that
sounds like weird and mysterious but if
you just have a universe made of photons
the photons lose energy as the universe
expands they redshift away so the total
amount of energy in the photons goes
down now if you have dark energy Dark
Energy wait in all fairness to the
photons yeah all right
I do want to be fair to the photons you
want to be there's a lot more of them
than there are of me fair to the protons
so the energy
density
is going
down yeah but the no isn't that number
don't do it it's not conserved no I
guess not it's really not yeah
but is it doing work on the expanding
Universe I mean what's okay well keep
going like I said it's it's not that
energy conservation is thrown out the
window but it's moved to a different
room in your house one in which it's not
as simple as just saying energy is
conserved there is a new rule in general
relativity that relates what is
happening in space-time to what is
happening with the energy
okay
new rules
new rules okay did anyone see that
coming from the classical era of
conservation of matter and energy you
know energy conservation turns out to be
a more slippery concept than you might
think again this is something with the
general relativity stuff that is just
perfectly clear from the equations
there's no problem with that but there's
a similar thing in quantum mechanics
where you know you measure a system and
its state changes and the energy of the
state can also change and people have
not appreciated until recently that that
means that yeah energy is not exactly
conserved to an observer in quantum
mechanics either so you gotta Gotta Keep
Your wits about you in this physics
stuff you know you can't just rely on
Old Faithful sayings and I think we we
used to always think of energy as this
sort of like buttoned up like uptight
guy who just never strayed from the
rules but that our conception of that
was wrong he's more like the leather
jacket the motorcycle
and he's breaking hearts along the way
by abandoning rules yeah and I think
energy would not make a good boyfriend
where would that analogy fail
if every analogy has a part that works
and a part that doesn't
I think you don't want energy to be your
boyfriend I think that's true okay
excuse me a dating podcast so there you
go
relationship advice is very important so
you want to date energy but you don't
want to you know get married to it
because it's just not reliable there you
go Nadine we got that solved
okay the next one what do you have in
the game all right so our next question
comes from Chris Hampton if you could
shrink enough to stand on an electron
how much how much would time dilate
relative to Standard Time how big would
the atom's nucleus scene and how far
away would other atoms be
one
I'm gonna give like a really set of
disappointing answers to these questions
these are these are good questions but
uh just so everyone knows you can't
shrink down to stand on an electron
that's not something you can do uh don't
believe every Marvel movie see uh I know
you didn't think that but okay just
verifying but the other thing is
remember again quantum mechanics comes
into the game you know we have this
picture in our minds of the atom like a
little solar system right like there's
the nucleus at the middle and there's
electrons orbiting around it like
planets it's not actually like that
you've been lied to by that little
cartoon picture the real electron is a
fuzzy cloud of probability so it's not
just that you can't shrink down small
enough to stand on it there's nothing
there to stand on there's no such thing
as the size of the electron so things
the rules of the game the rules of
existence the rules of Getting By from
moment to moment and are so incredibly
different if you're the size of an atom
that we would have to start from scratch
to figure out what was going on
by the way I took my child to like a
Disney exhibit this weekend where you
walked into these rooms where they did
shrink you down and because then we
walked into rooms where like popcorn
were really really huge
and like you had to lift them with both
hands it's possible that you didn't
actually shrink
okay
over
it's time continuum
all right and and something you just
slip by in your comment um Sean but I
think it's it Bears some some reflection
we do not have any knowledge
of the actual size of the electron
I would yeah I think that it's an
important point the way that I would say
it is there is no such thing as the size
of an electron the electron is not like
a Little P but smaller okay it's a
different kind of thing it's
intrinsically Quantum and you don't you
don't bump into those kinds of things in
your everyday life right but you can say
that the proton is a thing right proton
is more thing like
then an electron but it's a continuance
this official vocabulary here again so I
hope you're taking notes it's more thing
like that more objects like objects it's
a yeah yeah okay cool
all right I do have to say I feel like
you're totally just unseating all of the
imagery everything everything I knew the
rules this is just life you grow up you
go to school you learn things that are
all lies and you learn the truth on Star
Talk radio
that's the progression of an intellect
right right right right that's the
standard trajectory for people yeah oh
here's a question from David Smith David
writes it's been proposed that every
time a Quantum event occurs that can
have more than one possible outcome that
all possible outcomes occur and an
observer only sees one does an event
occurring actually create the different
results and where would the energy come
from to create these alternate particles
and is it a split in the universe as was
so commonly described in sci-fi people
are really worried about the energy
stuff today aren't they like what is
there something about like the heat wave
that is making people afraid that their
energy is not going to be up to the task
um but yes this is exactly a leading way
of thinking about quantum mechanics that
you say okay there's an electron and
it's in a superposition of spinning
clockwise and counterclockwise but then
the fact is when you look at it and
measure its spin you never see both of
them you see one or the other and
there's a leading theory says that
that's because there is a world a
parallel universe where there's the
electron spinning clockwise and you saw
it spinning clockwise and a separate
distinct Universe where the electron was
spinning counterclockwise and that's
what you saw in fact this is more or
less the straightforward prediction of
the equations that we've been lovingly
describing here and I wrote a whole
other book my previous book was called
something deeply hidden describing and
defending exactly that point of view so
I am someone who actually does think
that is really what happens not everyone
agrees yet but eventually I'm going to
place the minds of you sure that's where
it's headed yeah I know what's going to
happen I know which way so that means
I'm duplicated as well in that other
observation no you're the only one who's
not that's everyone else
there's only room for one Neil deGrasse
Tyson in the Multiverse
so we have a special dispensation thank
you well David actually has like an
addendum that kind of a crescendo to his
question which is what are the
ramifications for our ability or lack
thereof to change any events in our
lives and in simple terms is Free Will
precluded by the very nature of
existence
you will not be surprised answer that in
two sentences yeah that's an easy one I
just giving you a softball
sentences are it has absolutely nothing
to do with free will because what
matters for free will is not whether the
laws of physics are stochastic or
deterministic but rather there are laws
of physics at all I guess I only need
one sentence sorry
well I need I need a supplement to that
okay keep going
well it depends on what you mean by Free
Will right if you think that Free Will
is some somehow an ability of human
beings to not be guided by the laws of
physics then you are in trouble long
before quantum mechanics came along okay
I don't think that quantum mechanics is
very relevant here all quantum mechanics
says is we can't exactly predict what's
what the outcome will be but there's
still laws that say what the relative
probabilities are so I really don't
think the quantum mechanics com it
conflicts or helps Free Will in any way
that's a separate philosophical problem
could it be well philosophy is one of
the taglines of your profile so could it
be that what we perceive as free will is
some version of the probability space
that quantum mechanics grants its
particles
well I would say that's almost exactly
true but you don't even need quantum
mechanics to say it you could just say
it classically you don't know the
position and the velocity of every
molecule and atom in your body so when
we talk about human beings this is what
is called the compatibilist view of Free
Will which is the most common one among
philosophers when we talk about human
beings of course we talk in a language
of probabilities and choices and
volition and willpower because we are
not perfect calculating machines that
can say exactly what's going to happen
so it makes perfect sense to talk about
the Free Will that people have not
because they're able to overcome the
laws of physics but because that's the
best way we have of describing them in
the real world
okay so our perception of what's going
on is completely compatible with the
idea that we have free will yes
another way to think about that all
right
uh well let's look at a question from
Kira lesser Kira writes uh first of all
I'm very excited to read your book Dr
Carol can you explain what theory or
theories in physics imply we don't have
free will and why do we really know
enough to say that so you were sort of
getting at this yeah there are some
folks out there you know and you've read
them that are telling you that we don't
have free will
we're on the strong Carol Camp here so
we get to we get to side with you no
matter what you say so of course we do
believe in the laws of physics okay
there's this thing called this idea
called libertarian Free Will which has
nothing to do with political positions
or economics okay so don't be afraid
about that it's it's just the idea that
somehow the laws of physics don't apply
to human beings now let's say that we
don't believe that because we're a
well-trained natural scientists and we
think that we are made of atoms and we
do obey the laws of physics
that's not enough to say therefore we
don't have free will but it depends what
you mean by free will to me what free
will means is when I talk about a human
being
I say this is a person who has opinions
who uses reason and and thinking to
reach conclusions and I can persuade
them not correctly all the time yes they
use it
I'm very wishful thinking here a human
being who uses reason you know that's
that's pushing it there Sean maybe my
best friends use reason sometimes
but I can try to persuade them I mean
this is the hilarious thing about people
who don't believe in free will they're
constantly trying to make you change
your mind and why would they do that if
they didn't think you had free will
that's interesting
yeah the people who are certain you
don't have free will
are struggling to get people who believe
we have free will to believe them but
they're exercising their free will to
not believe that this is actually my
relationship with my toddler basically
that because it will make you crazy like
I'm telling her to do one thing she's
sort of like no do this other thing I
don't believe in your Authority I don't
believe in any Authority and then she
like you know vomits up some milk and
it's a very confusing situation and I
feel like it's exactly this Dynamic
you're talking about I think it's a
promising political philosophy that
she's developing
it's also undoes a lot of puzzles yeah
yeah imagine if at the heat of argument
you just vomited up the milk you just
drank
in the United Nations or in the halls of
Congress we kind of win arguments that
way I think that's what happens
all right keep them coming all right
Pablo Duart from Valencia Spain asks
scientists does it ended in E is it
Duarte no he wrote the pronunciation is
do art so I'm oh well at the end so just
do art I I wanted to say Duarte I did I
did want to say that but I didn't Pablo
Duart from Valencia Spain says
scientists have been struggling for
decades to come up with a Theory of
Everything do you think we can get there
with incremental steps further
developing existing theories or do we
need to wait for the next Newton or
Einstein to come up with a new and
Innovative approach I love that question
yeah that's kind of for everything like
do we need yeah of course which thing or
can we do it in steps we waited for that
person to be born I think that we will
get there uh I I see absolutely no
reason to think that human beings are
not up to the task of fully
understanding the universe in fact I
would flip it the other way around I
mean we've made amazing progress in
understanding the universe a hundred
years ago we didn't know that there were
other galaxies much less the Big Bang or
anything like that and just look at how
much we've learned in just a hundred
years which is nothing historically
speaking so I think we will get there
will it require a Newton or an Einstein
well guess what there's a lot of smart
people out there someone's going to get
it and then we will label them after the
fact just as smart as Newton and
Einstein so it's not a matter of waiting
for someone smart enough to do it just a
matter of the right place right time
right person who will put the final
touches on the puzzle
excellent excellent are we gonna take a
quick break before we go to our third
and final segment we're here with my
friend and colleague Sean Carroll and
the one and only Nadine facade my guest
co-host on StarTalk Cosmic queries
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries
Edition Sean Carroll's got a new book on
the biggest questions of the universe uh
and he's tackling space-time in motion
some of the fundamental things that give
physics
it's life force and I've got nagine for
Assad Nagin you uh your host of fake the
nation so you got your own podcast I'm a
host of fake the nation and you also
have regular on NPR's wait wait don't
tell me that's a that's a fine piece of
work right there I am and it's a really
really fun show and then the other thing
I wanted the listeners to know is that
I'm on the new Hillary Clinton show
called gutsy it's going to be available
on Apple TV in the um in the fall
whatever this podcast has dropped I
think all the episodes will be available
and so you get to see mean hills because
we're better now
um Chad about uh ways of um defeating
the haters out there in America
all right so you've been busy girl and
you have a toddler running around the
house okay yes just vomiting milk
one of the haters right right one of the
hey she must be defeated
so all right so give me you got some
more questions so
um we have from avenish Joshi from
Houston Texas they're right I am 11
years old I watched a show on Netflix
which also featured featured Dr Tyson
one of the astrophysicists mentioned let
a minute is this right one of the
astrophysics is mentioned Lehman Alpha
blobs what exactly are they and what
makes them so special oh okay I I can
handle this Sean on if you unless you
want to jump in on it I want to let you
do it because you're an actual
astrophysicist it's very astrophysics
that question yeah unless the universe
came from is my idea
is for you
yeah so he made he made the Earth and
I'm just a forest on the earth in my
reply to this question so what we
learned I guess a few decades now ago in
the 1980s
early 90s we learned that the universe
doesn't only have galaxies in it there
are these Blobs of hydrogen clouds that
are are are highly populated in the
voids of space and you don't otherwise
see them because they're not making
Stars actively the way regular galaxies
do but for other galaxies quasars far
away their light is trying to reach you
and in order to get to you that might
ends up piercing through these Blobs of
hydrogen clouds and for every one of
these it pierces through it leaves its
signature in the spectrum that you see
and there's tons of them in every
spectrum of a very distant Galaxy and
it's a feature it's behavior of the
hydrogen atom Lyman Alpha it's a feature
that you can measure in the Spectrum and
there's so many of these features it's
called the Lyman Alpha forest and so
that that's what that is so it's pretty
good job there Neil oh thank thank you
let me come back
maybe I'll be a guest on nagin's party I
didn't go that far we didn't go there
yeah okay yeah hold up all right okay so
next one
um well I'm gonna I'm gonna take things
down up a notch here and just get a real
serious uh by sharing a question from
David Rhodes David writes could the Big
Bang just be a cosmic fart from a
Celestial Giant
um
I love it because whenever physics
questions start with could it be
possible that the answer is always sure
yes it could be
I mean I don't know if that's the way to
go through your life thinking that
that's what the big bang was just to be
pop culture fluent here there's an
episode of Family Guy where that is
demonstrated uh I see it okay Cosmic
fart is
there's a deity that farts out our
universe in the Big Bang that's in an
episode of Family Guy just to be clear
on that but okay we would have to attach
some equations to the idea and make some
prediction for you know the abundance of
Light Elements from the early universe
and I'm testing this empirically
okay
probably there's more methane in a fart
than there was in the early universe so
it might be falsified I'm not sure oh
very I like that that's right because
typical farts are high methane yeah and
methane is carbon and hydrogen and there
wasn't much carbon in the very early
Universe
typical for it is high methane but uh
Cosmic bars again true right I mean
that's a loophole yeah exactly
Nadine you could easily have been
referee number two on this paper that
were that were writing pointing out just
I might as well slip it in here there
was a conversation I had with with Chuck
Nice and we were talking about the
powers of Superman and someone asked
would Superman eat superfood does he
have a super digestive tract and we just
followed that through if Superman is
super in every way superhuman in every
way he would have a super digestive
tract which might mean he would have
super farts and then we thought it has a
super fart which is high in methane he
could ignite
with his x-ray vision and then have a
flamethrower out his butt it would be a
new tool yes yes so as as Sean had been
toned there it is possible to pursue
questions such as that and see where
they take you in a serious way even if
they're asked uh with tongue-in-cheek
I'm not sure if I like this dark and
gritty reboot of Superman that you're
proposing here
this is a flamethrower you can use his
breath to freeze things he needs
something to burn things so there it is
okay who is who is his
gastroenterologist in that City
But Chuck like lost a gasket when he
imagined because he has to like roll
down his draws you know and then stick
his butt out and then make that happen
but oh yeah it's a little it's a little
it gets gets a little salacious for in
front of your kids and he's trying to
save from harm or whatever
okay so Nadine see if you can salvage
this conversation to back here we go
well you know what I'm gonna turn to
Zachary Keane from Nebraska who's
wondering since Dr Carroll has an
interest in quantum mechanics if he's
ever heard of quantum biology and his
thoughts on the idea that quantum
mechanics could play a role in the
biological processes of animals oh yeah
when I wrote my book on quantum
mechanics one of the bits of research I
did was to go to Amazon and type in the
word Quantum into the search bar looking
for what books have been written with
Quantum in the title and so there is
quantum yoga and Quantum leadership and
Quantum healing and Quantum prayer and
most of these the Quantum Leap don't
forget quantity the Schrodinger equation
appears in almost none of these books as
far as I can tell but Quantum biology is
very different because Quantum biology
actually does exist you know in one
sense everything is quantum like you and
I are quantum the table that in front of
me is quantum but the quantumness of it
doesn't show up very obviously the
classical physics way of thinking about
it is good enough for most purposes so
in Quantum biology you try to pinpoint
areas where processes happen that would
have been impossible in good old
Newtonian classical physics and so it's
thought for example that the way that
energy is transferred after
photosynthesis you know energy goes from
the leaf of the plant into its innards
and the way that it gets there requires
quantum mechanics to understand it sort
of takes different channels all at once
in a superposition so I think that's
very interesting and exciting I'm not an
expert in it myself but the world is
quantum so why shouldn't biology be but
that's describing the chemistry of the
process right so there is no
understanding of biology without
chemistry there's no understanding of
chemistry without physics so isn't it
all just physics in the end yep everyone
just learn physics and apply it to make
the world a perfect Utopia there you go
see I hated to make the subtext text
there but you know sometimes yeah
all right let's keep going the game
um let's make a good progress here yeah
we're really plowing through these here
we go Connor home
asks Dr Carol what do you find to be the
most fascinating thing in the universe
either observed or theorized and what do
you think or hope will be the next big
breakthrough in theoretical physics love
it I mean you're asking me to choose the
most fascinating thing in the universe
is like asking who's your which one is
your favorite child right you know like
I love everything in the universe
equally but I I do have a I have a song
it's not true it's not true it's not
true you could totally pick a child
online parents have to say it so right
but I have to say it I have a soft spot
for what we actually just talked about
at the intellectual high point of the
conversation which is that there is a
moment in the history of the early
Universe where the early universe is
like a nuclear fusion reactor it's
turning hydrogen into helium and other
elements by fusing them together and
that's pretty cool all by itself but
it's not that different than what
happens at the middle of the sun what's
what's interesting about it to me which
will what will never stop blowing my
mind is that this happens a matter of
seconds after the big bang okay we live
in a universe that's almost 14 billion
years old a few seconds after the big
bang nuclear fusion was going on and
we'd take the theories of physics that
were developed by us here on Earth with
our tiny little brains in the past 100
years and we extrapolate them back two
seconds after the big bang to make a
prediction for how much helium there
should be and how much lithium and all
that stuff and it's exactly spot on we
get it right we human beings are able to
use the power of physics to understand
what was going on a minute after the big
bang and it agrees with the data and
that just will never cease to amaze me
cool yeah uh I don't even know what to
say to that but like except
brag like just a brag for humans oh yeah
oh yeah what do you mean I mean he said
my favorite I'm not going to pick the
thing that makes us look dumb there's
plenty of those
yeah like uh I don't know
um Amer like like American cheese that
one makes us look dumb no cheese whiz
she's whiz
yeah like there's a lot of uh you know
but he he you know yeah you have to take
the there's got to be a lot of asterisk
in there that includes all of the
cheeses that we did again I'm just
trying to think about go to ancient
France where they have their famous
cheeses yeah and say one day they'll be
a country where they put cheese
that will bastardize this art yeah
thinking about you know the list of
accomplishments of the 20th and 21st
century humanity and like we have room
for one more should it be a big bang or
cheese in a can we have easy cheese
opinions differ
just like a couple more okay here we go
from Tony Thompson he writes we continue
to break down matter further and further
as we explore molecules to atoms atoms
to neutrons and protons then to quarks
Etc in theory if we ever reach the most
fundamental building blocks in the
universe would it be logically possible
to prove it or will the search for
Spartacus or will the search for smaller
particles always exist I love that I
love that yeah so let me restate that
Sean we have our base particles that
were taught in physics what confidence
do we have that they cannot be further
broken apart
so I think the way we just like that the
Greeks who said the atom is indivisible
right and then we divide the atom and so
the word doesn't even make any sense
anymore though we still use it so yeah
it was the it was the Chemists in the
18th century who really caught on to the
idea of atoms and they sort of leapt a
little bit too quickly in assigning the
word Adam which is the Greek word
meaning indivisible to their little
building blocks of chemical elements
because of course then we discovered
that they are divisible right into
electrons and nuclei the nuclei are
divisible into protons and neutrons the
protons and neutrons are divisible into
quarks and gluons but the point is that
by this point by the time you get to the
quarks and gluons the businesses are not
complete dummies like they caught on
that this is a really good thing to do
like you could become famous if you
figure out that the particles that we
know about are made of pioneer particles
right that's a route to success so
everyone asks this question and what you
do is you do science you say if it were
true that electrons and quarks and so
forth are made of smaller particles how
would we know and can we build a theory
in which that's true and people have
tried to build theories in which that's
true and they are constantly disproven
by the data
so you don't ever in science prove that
something is the final answer but what
you can do is disprove a whole bunch of
other things and eventually you're left
with the remaining possibility so I'm of
the opinion that there need not be a
very deep further set of layers of
reality below what we currently know it
could be a completely different kind of
stuff right it might not be new
particles at all but I don't think we're
just going to continue to find smaller
and smaller particles out of which the
things we now know are made
that's very not Men In Black you realize
I need to we need to have the talk about
taking Hollywood movies as documentaries
again yes
you know are we a snow globe on the
mantle of an alien you know right our
entire universe is what that is I think
we don't have any time for more
questions I'm sad oh my gosh but let me
find out where can we find you Nagin on
social media yes can find me at negin
farsad
n-e-g-i-n-f-a-r-s-a-d on all of the
things and I am even on Tick Tock where
I really I do spare the people my my
dance moves okay
and Sean uh you got it you're you're
active in all spaces so where should we
direct people first multimedia the book
uh that uh is out fall 2022 the biggest
ideas in the universe I think it's a
great way to dig a little bit more
deeply into the ideas of physics than
you usually get a chance to and then the
podcast mindscape where every week we
talk about some big mind-blowing Ideas
it's a lot of fun and you have great
videos that are all collected are they
in your own videos you can just go to my
website which is
preposterousuniverse.com you can find
the blog the podcast the videos the
books the whole shebang excellent
excellent okay uh Sean it's been great
to have you again and keep us in mind
every time you do some
good luck with the Hillary show
what's it called again I called the
Hillary show what's the name it's called
gutsy that's the that's the Hillary show
okay
there it is we'll be looking for that so
uh excellent but this has come to a
close we're Landing the plane right now
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and you've been listening
to possibly even watching our Cosmic
queries Edition with Sean Carroll as
always keep looking up
[Music]